what is it like going from a period
comedy to
an action-packed hawkeye
set where you play kate bishop it
couldn't be
more different um but it's uh it's it's
a fun change of pace i just i love
what i do so much for that reason i i'm
in one world one day and a completely
different one the next um
but it's been so fun to have this
opportunity creatively
and just having lived in this world of
dickinson that i'm so thankful i get the
opportunity to go back to
because i get to take a step back and
think you know in my own time
um just obviously about the character
and about the progression of things
um and to be able to walk away and sort
of
enter a new headspace and then come back
with with a fresh
outlook um i feel like is is just
amazing as an artist to have the
opportunity to do to do that but i'm i'm
honored to be involved in both projects
what
about kate are you excited to bring to
the screen
without your version will surprise fans
you know
oh i mean i i
i'm just so excited as i am in the
process of developing her i'm working
with some incredible
filmmakers that are helping me bring her
to life i can't wait for people just to
see how
we are interpreting this character
through the comics um
and and in our own sort of ways um she's
such a badass there's no denying that
she's so smart and witty and quick and
um her physical ability
to do so many things is through the roof
it's really
it's tested me and it's kept me uh going
through quarantine i will say it's given
me a reason to
stay with it um but i'm just uh very
excited as i continue developing her
um to see sort of how we um come up with
it
what if i don't want fame
how do you want to be remembered i feel
like the big theme
of this season is that emily is really
facing
issues of fame and notoriety and does
she want it does she not want it
how would you kind of describe her
journey that she goes on in season two
i mean the journey is trying to find and
those uh the answers to those questions
that you sort of just threw out there
it's
you know what's gonna happen if i if my
life goes from
being in the corner of my bedroom at
this tiny desk
with one reader right of my poems
to possibly the world
emily again is searching for the answers
to
what is fame exactly i don't want to
disappear from this earth without
anybody knowing who i am
what is the meaning of that what
determines that
am i opening myself up to a world of
judgment and all this sort of self-doubt
comes over her
she's never ever had an issue with
sitting down and writing and suddenly
she's just like overtaken and consumed
by this idea of
of fame and attention and it's something
she's always thought
she wanted um and and we sort of imagine
that like that's something she's
she must want right i can't be your only
reader anymore
you need to share your writing with the
world and so it's just sort of this
crazy back and forth rollercoaster right
of her trying to figure out what the
heck she really wants
you